good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy wednesday it is a
hump day hope everyone's doing great hey
jax how you doing i'm doing good you
know it's hump day which means we're
getting over the hump this week it does
feel like it deserves to be a thursday
i'm not gonna lie i couldn't agree more
but imagine my surprise when i woke up
and it wasn't tuesday like i was just
thought it was tuesday this the first
half of the hump did go by rather
quickly oh so we're saying opposite
things yeah but like of course it should
always be a thursday okay you just like
vehemently agreed with me and of course
no i didn't disagree i agree with your
right to be alive on a thursday like
i'll never take that away from you yeah
so i'm really looking forward to
tomorrow but in order to get to tomorrow
we have to get through today you know i
do feel that like it should be a
thursday that's what i'm saying but also
grateful for a wednesday because you
know what it's on a tuesday and a date
on monday that's true and you get to hum
someone you love so you know call do
call brew get the boys out here
it's going down because you know what
we them boys
we making no we making we making i did a
little remix we making noise i'm just in
this like musical headspace because i
told you yesterday i've been working a
lot on my song okay um it's pretty much
done like can you give us a tease can
you give us like a lyric
yeah okay you know what i can i actually
we came up with this like last week and
by we i mean my songwriter felipe like i
didn't do it um but last week we were
doing the bridge and he came up with a
lyric that references toast which like i
just love loved so much just cut should
i sing it or just like say the line
whatever you feel more comfortable with
a toast to us the wild ones
toast to the wild one so that was just
like really exciting that is exciting i
know the pitch is gonna need work
sorry that just like wasn't your best
but i know her by the way
hurt me where it actually hurts you know
but i know that like the song is gonna
like you have an amazing voice you just
like didn't grace us with it this
morning
you
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that's like
hurting you like right at your core like
i don't even know what i could say to
her i'm here to make like to
make you better stronger the best
version of you you know what
i'm good no no um no i won't let you put
out mediocrity put out mediocrity i
can't [ __ ] talk to you anymore you're
so [ __ ] negative oh my god i'm so
supportive put out you just don't mind
supporting you're not going to know your
girlfriend put out mediocrity like i was
just i wasn't performing i was just like
sharing a lyric like you don't have to
analyze everything okay
okay fine it's already a hard day for me
like christine and cody from cysterwigs
are broken up like you have no you have
no sympathy for what i'm going through i
don't because i don't know what it means
and i'm going to need you to explain it
to me
yeah of course we're talking about that
we're also talking about vanderpump
roles that was on last night um and it's
just like a good hump day to be alive
yes yes it is we're in the thick of
november i'm really feeling this
november energy you know i'm really
liking the space that we're in i i would
like the space that i was into if i
lived in a home where i could see the
outside so yeah my bunker doesn't really
allow me to understand the seasonal
changes got it but like when you leave
your house are you freezing you're
feeling it yeah i mean i got my coat on
today sherpa and there she is yeah i
love being you know in the cold weather
but today was just like a little colder
than i expected i forgot to watch the
weather snitch
and i didn't realize like it's full it's
fully winter outside yeah today i
watched the weather snitch and she told
me what i needed to know so i put on
this little cozy little buzzer that has
little pictures it's really cute teddy's
ted i'm gonna wear it to the ted 3
premiere
you'll be waiting a long time
i won't be getting in literally
no i actually think they would
appreciate the originality and
creativity and the the motivation and
spirit for the brand for sure but they'd
be like girl you're wearing a sweatshirt
to a premiere gets [ __ ] out yeah i
guess that's very true yeah um
what was i gonna say
about my sweater
no whatever i can't remember um i'm just
excited to chat you know i love chatting
great chat cha-cha-cha did you do
something with your makeup today no
it looks like you have like a smokey eye
no you didn't do the browns i've been
doing the brown like every day it looks
like since you did my makeup it looks
like a different color brown holy [ __ ]
yes i used a different bronzer like as
here as my lid wow you're
very observatory i'm observant i'm
always paying attention always it's a
little annoying like
pay less attention
pay less shoe source okay
it's who i am are payload shoe sources
still in business i haven't seen one in
a while what's their bogo energy
oh they rebranded yeah it's just called
paybass it's a payless shoe source
anymore no if it ever was a hundred
percent it was okay it's just payless
was it payless shoe source or payless
shoe stores i think source now that i
think about it like such a bizarre name
for
a store yeah but that's why i think it
was just called payloads yeah no i do
think that they eventually rebranded to
payless i'm being dead serious okay no
this is this is a quick google okay
hopefully it's working out for them i
hope they're still in business but i
don't think i don't know
if there ever were there was one i
remember
payless shoe source they are called
payless now they still have a website
but yes the store in queens on google
it's payless shoe source i guess it
hasn't updated to the new name they
haven't gotten the new branding from the
headquarters yet yeah honestly like
kind of craving a payless shoe source
right now they had some bomb bogo sales
buy one get one
um so yeah today it's just gonna be a
fabulous regular day of the toast i feel
like it's been so long since we've had
like normalcy here because
there i was in italy then there was the
covet exposure and then there was
halloween and now i'm just so excited to
be like in my regular clothes yes
sitting and chatting sitting and
chatting on my side
of the the set yes but we did have a
regular show yesterday yeah no i know
i'm just i'm getting back into the
groove you know i'm such a routine based
girl i don't know if you know that about
me i would say that you are really
you're a creature of habit creature of
habit and you know what i remember what
i was gonna say five minutes ago you
know what i did yesterday that i think
i'm gonna start implementing into my
everyday life
while i was getting ready for the toast
i put on the today show so when when i
get ready it's like the third hour of
today and it's just like nonsense like
some celebrity interviews yesterday i
saw the guy from the sopranos and the
golf player i don't know i just feel
like it was a good way to start my day
like that's interesting because this
morning i
put on give them lala with randall
because someone told me that she talks
about the randall situation at 2 27 and
i had to go run and listen and i did and
like she what she says is that she won't
be talking about it she's not ready to
talk about it her daughter needs privacy
please respect that and then she talks
about how it's affected her sobriety
which um spoiler alert it's been totally
fine okay and she actually feels
stronger than ever in her sobriety
during this time um but then i was like
sitting there doing my makeup listening
to a podcast and i was like you know
this is kind of nice it's like a little
companion so i was like maybe i should
start listening to a podcast before i
get ready for the toast but it would
have to be something like so
different from our show because you know
what i planned i don't want to yeah it
would influence like what i say and then
i started like with talking like these
people and like i'd like to have my own
thing going on yeah so i think i i don't
know i would have to be just
something completely random yeah well
the third hour of the today show is not
like the best i would say i think who
posts it um al roker's there and i don't
know the other three people and they
were doing like fun you know fashion
segments you know cable and sweaters are
back in style um and they had a bunch of
celeb interviews and just like travel
segments so it's just like real like
giving me you know morning glory vibes
giving you nothing giving me nothing but
just like everything at the same time
like inner peace like just knowing like
there's so much going on in the world
like this is what these people are
talking about it's kind of like
everything you know yeah um but i do
wish like my schedule better synced up
with like hoda you know because i think
that's probably if i were to
associate myself with like any hour of
the today show would probably be the
fourth got it which i think is hoda and
jenna
but no um i'm stuck in the third hour
and it's i don't know i just kind of
like felt like an adult like watching
cable in the morning like crazy yeah no
that's it's an interesting
it's an interesting prospect i might
have to find like the right podcast that
talks about nothing that we talk about
what do you usually listen to or do with
your when you're doing your makeup and
your hair in the morning pretty much
silence sometimes music if it's friday
or if there's like an album that came
out that i'm really wanting to say to
but sometimes when i put on music it
makes me move slower because i'm like
enjoy i'm like and these days i'm always
in a rush because i'm always like now i
have to like make breakfast before i
leave the house because i'm always
hungry so so cute that like takes up
time or i like to just get as much sleep
as i can and then like rush the makeup
oh that's my favorite thing to do yeah
um so yeah that's pretty much it for me
what about you anything else you want to
share with the group oh
i watched brittany murphy i saw
it was really upsetting yeah
i have to watch your guys's recap of it
okay um but i kind of like that towards
the end i like how the documentary was
called what happened to brittany murphy
and like we still don't know but the
overall consensus like there isn't this
major conspiracy like she probably
wasn't poisoned but she was controlled
and
manipulated so much to the point where
like she wasn't able to take care of
herself and like she literally died of
like neglect neglect yeah like like this
is gonna sound terrible but like a dog
like we don't feed a dog like
it's so
it was so upsetting and so much
weirdness i you know we were so young i
don't really remember and i was never
really invested in the story but i loved
her as an actress uptown girls all that
stuff
but the mom and the boyfriend on larry
king like it was so crazy like you can't
believe this stuff actually happened
yeah
yeah that's what we said you should
check it out i i'm sure we have the same
opinion yeah no i want to watch it but
it was i thought it was very well done
it was i made a tour trust with a
thousand pieces you know no
two hours two parts is good
it's good okay so without further ado we
have a lot to talk about today so let's
jump right into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
organifi a line of organic superfood
blends that offer plant-based nutrition
made with high quality ingredients each
organifi blend is a science-backed craft
to the most effective doses with
ingredients that are organic and free of
fillers and contain less than three
grams of sugar per serving the organifi
green juice with essential superfoods
and a clinical dose of ashwagandha it
helps reduce stress support healthy
cortisol levels and the organifi gold
which is a superfood tea that supports
rest and relaxation so you can wake up
feeling refreshed each organifi blend is
easy to use by simply mixing it with
water or your favorite beverage while on
the go and they don't compromise the
quality for taste organifi takes pride
in offering the best tasting superfood
products on the market
at a price that works to just less than
three dollars a day you can experience
organifi's high quality superfoods
without breaking the bank go to
organifi.com toast and use the code
toast for twenty percent off your order
that's o r g a n i f i dot com backslash
toast use code toast for 20
off any item
great okay our first story britney
spears is speaking out and she's blaming
her mom for giving her dad the idea of a
conservatorship
so brittany took to instagram as she
always does but in a now deleted
instagram post last night where she was
spilling some tea she's talking about
the moment that she smiled she said i
realize i haven't in a very long time my
mom gets so concerned and says you're
acting weird what's wrong with you i say
hi my name is britney spears nice to
finally meet you anyway she said my dad
may have started the conservatorship 13
years ago but what people don't know is
that my mom is the one who gave him the
idea i will never get those years back
she secretly ruined my life and yes i
will call her and lou taylor out on it
so take your whole i have no idea what's
going on attitude and go [ __ ] yourself
you know exactly what you did my dad is
not smart enough to ever think of a
conservatorship but tonight i will smile
knowing i have a new life ahead of me
you know what i think for a while like
of course the villain of the story has
always been jamie spears and i think
like
not people who are so so so invested in
the movement but just like people who
have been following
and myself included are really unsure of
like where other members of the family
like have landed in this whole thing
like were they team britney were they
secretly just like stealing her money um
and slowly but surely she has
peeled back the layers and showed us
like it's not just jamie here like he's
for the face of this thing yeah but it's
really the whole family who were just
like all on board all living off the
estate um and he couldn't do this alone
because if everybody else in the family
had brittany's back then like he would
be the outcast and it's like what are
you doing right grifter yeah but he
clearly had the support of other members
of the family if he was able to get away
with this and usually like my philosophy
is like i do not support
really no matter what's going on like
airing your dirty laundry family stuff
publicly like i just think you know
family stuff should remain private but
this i'm like living for every instagram
caption like more and more and more
can't post enough can't get enough that
ethos doesn't apply here because it's
been aired it was
13 years ago when they took her to court
and put her under a conservatorship and
they put her life even more out in the
public like this isn't you know
family tings like this is straight up
betrayal agreed but you know it's
it's just not something i naturally like
lean into yeah you know yeah but i i do
feel like you know the this is an
exception the lines have been crossed
here there's there are none like it's
fair game what they did to her nothing
she could ever say or ever do would
compare to what they did to her so if
she wants to take little jabs here and
there go off queen go off queen there's
also a lot of talk i've been seeing
especially on dumas like about a
potential disney biopic and like how
allegedly like margot robbie is dying to
play brittany um and brittany's been
like rejecting all these scripts and she
posted a video on her instagram like
i've been getting all these scripts
about my life and like they're all just
filled with lies like who's gonna write
a movie about me nobody knows what i've
been going through for the last 13 years
so why doesn't she get involved i'm sure
she will she's busy like she's just got
her freedom like yeah she needs to live
a little bit but i definitely think
there should and probably will be a
movie and i do think margot robbie's the
perfect person to play her yeah she
should take some time off and then she
should be executive producing that
helping with the script like it should
really be britney's story told at a very
like high level and it should be based
on like real things from the person who
experienced it and like we do need one
official
britney movie doc or something because
we have all these other ones that she's
like saying like stop even though
they're like so critically creamy and
they're healthy britney spears britney
versus spears like her and sam are like
stop making money off of her
yeah so we need her to get involved in
the official one to put all the other
ones to bed and also so i know which one
to watch you know i want to watch the
britney approved one i want to watch the
one that brittany's involved in and i
assume
not yet obviously because again she's
just like she's been taking like a
million vacations she can finally like
travel without going through like having
to put in paperwork like she could just
go yeah um i think there'll be like a
movie a book
i think there'll be all of that in due
time in due time i'm in no rush i'm not
putting any pressure on brit like live
your life go on your vacations do your
dances like just be happy yeah i agree
take your time okay our next story
sister wives christine brown splits from
cody brown after 25 years she says we've
grown apart christine announced the pair
split on instagram tuesday saying the
longtime couple had grown apart quote
after more than 25 years together cody
and i have grown apart and have made the
difficult decision to leave we will
continue to be a strong presence in each
other's lives as we parent our beautiful
children and support our wonderful
family at this time we ask for your
grace and kindness as we navigate
through this stage with our family okay
so let me just give you the back story
here sisterwise is a show on tlc about
this literal like monster named cody who
has the show started with three wives
and they acquired a fourth one um along
the way
it's actually right when the show
started and it was like all this tension
because like robin who was the new wife
was like this hot young thing and like
it was definitely weirdness so the first
woman he married was mary
and they have one kid together and i
think that if i if you ask me or any
sister wives fan like who would be the
first wife to leave it was always gonna
be mary like it was just
she was so unhappy always um and he
legally married her
a million years ago like in the 90s and
they were married and then they got
other wives but what is the basis for
their polygamy like i believe they're
mormon okay but like they're always
fleeing different communities like the
show started in utah they live in
flagstaff now they moved to nevada at
some point like i don't know like what
church i think they're real
like outsiders like of their community
so
he married mary legally and then when
they decided to become like polygamous
they brought on janelle but he only
married her spiritually of course you
can't legally have multiple marriages so
the woman he was always married to was
mary the first one then janelle then
christine who's the one who just left
then when robin came along when they got
the show he legally separated from the
original wife mary to legally marry
robin and that just changed the down
like why did you not legally separate
from mary to marry janelle
so there were there has just been so
much weirdness since since then and when
you watch the show i haven't
watched up or kept up with every episode
but like these are miserable people like
everything they do is just miserable
like
the living conditions like everything is
just miserable they're unhappy people so
i i'm not surprised that a wife left i
am surprised one that it took this long
and b that it was christine but
allegedly i didn't watch last season at
the end of the episode they had moved to
flagstaff and christine was just like i
don't know what i'm doing here like
where where i'm so unhappy like so to
people who are really devout watchers of
the show it's not surprising but i do
think that a lot of people would have
assumed mary would have gone first
because she's just like an unhappy woman
maybe christine is breaking down the
door oh yes and now the women they'll
they might see how christine fares out
there yeah you know but i'm sure she'll
get like a condo and a new man and a boy
maybe too and yeah and then mary will be
like if christine can do it i can do it
see and mary only shares one kid with
cody christine who just left shares five
whoa
so it's just like a lot and you know
what i need a big condom i think a part
of the reason why
these women don't leave is because of
the show so i don't know what the hell
they do for a living but like they have
five homes like because they have five
well you know what i mean
they literally i remember when they
moved to nevada they bought a whole
cul-de-sac because of each other they
each have their own home and he spends
certain nights so except in the first
house they lived in utah it was
literally like this one home with four
apartments it was so sad oh my god wait
so couldn't christine just stay in her
solo home probably oh well even i mean i
don't know if she would want to it's
like it's so toxic jackie like you watch
one episode you don't know how these
people live and you really feel bad for
the kids when you said like they own
five homes i was like she could go stay
in another one no it's all they're all i
don't know they're all on one street i
don't know what the flagstaff conditions
are but the last time i watched a show
in nevada they were all on a cul-de-sac
it was like four identical model homes
how does this man afford all of this
right and if it wasn't for the show like
how does one man live a polygamous
lifestyle exactly comfortably so when
the show first started they were living
in one home with three apartments and
like that would make sense for how like
one guy supports three wives right but
now i think the show pays them very well
i know they they do
oh here's the best part i cannot believe
i forgot to tell you this mary the
initial wife
is a lularoe retailer queen
so there's just like all these things
going on um and yes so the show is a
major part of it i think they make a lot
of money from the show like who would
walk away from that like they went from
living in one home with four families to
living in a cul-de-sac you know yeah so
it's it's a very
complex dynamic i would say got it okay
well thank you for that brief explainer
i'm i'm rooting for christine i hope
that you know she
lives a happy fruitful life and that she
can inspire other women within her own
family and maybe other women elsewhere i
know it's easy for me to say this
because she left like she was always my
favorite but the thing is is like every
season i remember mary's always been
like miserable there was a time when
janelle the second wife was like super
amazed and he thought she was gonna
leave so it's like kind of a thing with
their show it's like every season some
wife is miserable about something but
none of them ever actually leave and i
just think that this is like a pivotal
moment
wow
okay so wait i'm looking at this picture
which one is christine all the way on
the left okay okay i'll do a little
thing for you okay okay christine
first wife mary wow she got shoved all
the way to the end that's mary she's the
lularoe retailer the one in the pink
this is on the people magazine article
that's robin that's the hot young thing
that came in at the beginning of the
show and she's the disrupter okay
obviously the middle monster is cody i
don't know how this man pulled four
women he's so weird-looking um and then
the little short one is janelle okay
cute yeah janelle went through this
major weight loss a couple years ago i
think she lost like over 100 pounds wow
yeah no it's kind of like an interesting
it's it's own planet the sister wives
universe you know yeah so i i think a
lot of people like vacation
so that's the tea that's the tea um
yeah where are my fellow sister wifers
at like obsessed i started watching the
show in high school like and i don't
keep up with it anymore but when it's on
i'll obviously watch it's like see what
the gang's up to the kids have gotten so
old how many kids totally a thousand
like
uh probably like ten
merry and uh six between the two wives
robin had her own kids before okay and
then her and cody had some so there's
like a so this is like blended on
steroids
it's the blended wives yeah no this is
like blended to the next level yeah
times four four different homes to the
nth degree yeah 100
great are you ready for our next story
um is it the next story that's brought
to you by ship station it is that's
great because the holidays are the most
wonderful time of year we were literally
just talking about that but if you're
running an online store you know it can
also be the craziest and busy time of
your year so if you've got inventory to
manage orders to fill and a growing list
of stressed out customers checking in
twice a day wondering those last minute
gifts are going to arrive on time check
out shipstation the hassle of shipping
out holiday orders melts away leaving
you with happy customers and more
freedom to run your business if you sell
anything online we don't need to tell
you that shipping can be very
frustrating so many carriers tons of
factors that go into figuring out the
best rate for each order and with more
people shopping online every year
especially given the pandemic
shipstation is making the easy part of
running your business online your
shipping you can get back to doing what
you're passionate about which is growing
your business they help you easily
import your orders from every sales
channel whether that's amazon ebay etsy
or even your own website and they
automate just about any shipping task
it's all used on one easy to use
dashboard you can change your shipping
solution it can seem daunting to do that
but you'll be so much happier
shipstation works with all major
carriers international and local like
fedex usps and ups
98 of companies that use shipstation for
a year keep using it for as long as
they're in business it's that good make
this holiday season a little brighter
with shipstation use our offer code
toast to get a 60-day free trial just
enough time to handle the holiday
shipping rush just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the
the page and enter code toast ship
station make ship happen love it okay
next story
lisa arena and harry hamlin's daughter
delilah bell hamlin says she was
hospitalized after overdosing on
prescription drugs okay delilah bell
hamlin took to instagram the other night
to share her story in a nearly 30 minute
video that was originally an ig live
that she then uploaded to her instagram
so you can go and watch it she said
here's my story i guess and she
reflected on the past year of her search
for answers about her health she noted
that some people who remain unnamed told
her not to talk about what she
experienced yeah they were made unnamed
but i feel as though she made it pretty
clear it was her mom okay so this us
weekly article has a lot of the details
of um what she experienced she said this
is scary to do basically in the
beginning of the year i want to say
february and march is when i got my
coven 19 vaccine and after the second
vaccine i was sick for like 36 hours i
felt like my bones were breaking but
like whatever that's when everything
kind of started
she then recalled flying home from the
uk to get her second dose of the
modernist shot which wasn't available at
the uk at the time following her 11 hour
flight she had a severe panic attack and
called her housekeeper for help she said
she called her housekeeper for help not
her mom yes she said that she didn't
think her parents would come down
so i read this article and i was still
really confused because there's so much
information in here so i watched the
whole video okay i watched like half of
it because it was long to get uh to try
and understand what she was saying
because there's a lot to what she you
know she's going through
so much yeah there are so many things
going on she said i didn't realize that
the vaccine would cause an autoimmune
response in my body basically it flared
up and triggered certain autoimmune
diseases that i didn't know i had i
started getting really sick i started
feeling like i had the flu i was getting
migraines i was having panic attacks and
it was like my body was in constant
fight or flight mode it was horrible
so
she the vaccine for her triggered like
these dormant autoimmune diseases that
she didn't know she didn't know she had
pandas and then also um
like this anxiety disorder that was
giving her terrible
attacks then also inflammation of the
brain then she got tested for
tick-borne illnesses
and that's when she was like you know
which is so ironic
and so
that has people wondering if she didn't
want to share her story because she has
lyme disease right and she her mother
doubted the fact that yolanda didn't
accuse her of having munchausen syndrome
right so that is one of the many
ailments that she's struggling with and
so eventually by the way the way that i
perceived it was that her mom didn't
want her to say it publicly because
essentially what she's saying is like
this whole thing is as a result of the
vaccine yes and she said i'm not
anti-vaccine this is just what happened
to me and i i think this is a very rare
thing to happen but she doesn't i don't
think lisa wanted her kid out there like
making a political statement yes uh
there are people who think that and also
she never said it was her mom who didn't
want her to say
someone close to her didn't want to say
and throughout the the video there's
like moments where it's like her parents
are very much there for her and then
there are also moments where it's like
she calls her housekeeper she called her
housekeeper also she was very sick and
she had to go do a shoot in portugal and
her mom still made her go she was like
our mom has just taught us you know like
even if you're dying like you have to
work like a strong work ethic but you
know
there is there is a line and then she
also said that her and her family found
this facility for her to go to in
arizona where she could like detoxify so
also
the main headline here was that she was
having really terrible panic attacks she
started seeing a psychiatrist who over
prescribed her xanax she became
extremely dependent on xanax taking
three milligrams a day three milligrams
a day which is so much and she's a tiny
tiny person yeah
and so she was on that medication and
one night she also took benadryl and she
had to go to the hospital she
accidentally overdosed right and the
headline is misleading the headline is
misleading and also that's just like one
piece of this whole story right because
then when she figured out she was being
overprescribed on xanax she went off of
it but you can't if you're like heavily
reliant on xanax and you go off of it
almost immediately it triggers seizures
so then she started having seizures she
went to this facility in arizona to
detox and they were going to take care
of her and she was so excited and she
felt like she was getting better and she
was like weaning off of the xanax but
she they asked her to leave because she
was like a medical liability because she
was having seizures she was scaring the
staff she said one day just her legs
didn't work and she collapsed and got a
concussion she hit her head and they
asked her to leave and so and i think
that's where she is now like she i think
she left recently and she like doesn't
know what to do where to turn and i
think she just like turned to her
instagram because she's like out of
ideas and she should talk to yolanda
i think that's what like people were
commenting it's a really really sad
story and she talks about how her like
boyfriend's been there through so
anyways
family was interesting because she was
like my family and i found this facility
but then she also said that she had to
pay for it herself
that she had to like invest her money
into it into going which was like an
interesting factoid yeah so there's like
the delilah piece of it there's the
health piece of it and then of course
you know
it all and there's rina like what is
rina
thinking right and they are filming
yeah
no by the way i do think that
your reasoning for rena wanting her not
to say it is
better is that like more yolanda than
vaccine yeah i thought when i first
heard it like i was like of course lisa
doesn't want to put her kid in the
middle like her kid becomes a face of
like anti-vaxx or whatever i mean she's
said multiple times that this she's not
that this is just what happened right no
she's not lying so i that's what i
immediately thought but honestly um the
way you just phrased it like her lisa
not wanting delilah to say anything
because of the munchausens of it all i
actually think that's a more and that
she's having these inexplicable health
issues that are occurring internally
that you don't necessarily see
externally and it's a it's literally
what happened back
to you know yolanda no that's crazy
it sounds like
justice for yolanda yeah but it's a
really like sad i know she's so young to
be experiencing all of these health
issues and they just like keep
compounding one another right like once
she finds a solution for one thing
and now she's on antibiotics antivirals
psychiatric medication there was another
um
the medicine that she accidentally
overdosed on wasn't xanax it was called
pro
um
propran
propranolol i don't know but i mean when
you're taking this many medications
and again and she's tiny so like
it's a lot yeah
damn that's so crazy yeah i really hope
she's okay she's such a nice girl she's
so nice of video she's just like really
feeling helpless and her dog was snoring
the whole time
and it was so cute bruno was like what
who where no by the way that was theo
during this week's episode of curb did
you watch like at the dog cafe yeah theo
lost his [ __ ] mind oh my god this
week's episode of curb um the fact that
she calls her dog angel muffin you know
that's what i call bruce no but like i
don't think that's a weird name at all
no not at all but i'm always like to
talk we're making angel muffins tonight
like
like i actually call him angel muffin so
it's not that far-fetched of a name no
it's extremely relatable he's a muffin
made from angels very true soft buttery
delicious it's very simple
um so really wishing delilah bell all
the best that's really tough
same
next story switching gears nick lachey
will be missing out on the best book
ever written because he reveals he's
never read his ex-wife jessica simpson's
memoir and that he never willed he said
i know what the truth is oh oh please
such a gaslighter well he was on um
radio andy and andy asked him oh sorry
really quickly that just reminded me of
something the craziest part about the
whitney brittany murphy documentary is
the clips of ashton kutcher on the
howard stern show
where howard stern calls bernie murphy
the fat ugly chick from clueless he's
like yeah that's who you're dating right
now the fat ugly chick yeah but uh she
was a really menchie about it really i
thought he could have been mentioned
really he was like well basically what
he said he's like you know in hollywood
the ugly girl is always like a pretty
girl like with glasses well
he's doing an interview but he he really
doesn't like get in the mud with howard
like he not like yeah and she turned it
around like he was like she was always
beautiful i knew i just felt like he
could have like stood up for his
girlfriend more i thought she i thought
he was menchie no i wouldn't say menchie
but he could have been worse
yeah okay fine i like i hated that
interview and you know it pains me
because i love howard and i really
believe in his growth yeah but it was
really weird to hear like yeah no it was
awful awful but i i mean also like
ashton that is his girlfriend so he's
like also insulting ash and like right
it was but and i thought like he handled
it well for being in an interview and
not being like i'm leaving you know what
i mean but also um
during the narrative around like talk
making it about hollywood you know
okay i know like i don't see it that way
at all he should have stood up for his
girlfriend way more and like walked out
of the interview okay like a hundred
percent if zach was doing an interview
and somebody called you fat and ugly
like you would want him to leave okay
but like it's just
like it's just different
how like it's just different
because it's not you
yeah that's true cool okay so anyways
radio andy
uh nick lachey went on radio andy and
revealed that he has not given his
ex-wife's memoir a read and that he
won't be doing so in the future he said
you'd be shocked to hear that i have not
nor will i ever read it he said here's
the thing obviously i knew the book was
coming out i lived the book i know what
the truth is so i don't need to read it
or read someone's version of a story i
know it i lived it so no i never read it
okay well i guess he's not saying you
know outright that it's full of lies but
you know what it obviously was not a
flattering portrayal of him when i think
back on it
i don't think he came off so bad like
when i have to die i can't remember all
the details but if i had to diagnose
what went wrong is that they had two
very different ideas of what a marriage
should be
i would diagnose it as when they met she
was up and coming he was at the height
of his fame and throughout their
marriage she became a star and he was on
his way down and he really struggled
with not being the most famous person in
the marriage yes but i think also
you know and and that's why they worked
when they were dating because like they
had this you know separate lives
dynamics worked for him and worked for
her she was like fine with being like
you know she was excited to be more
famous yeah and like opening for them
and all that stuff but then i think he
thought marriage would be you know like
the man is the breadwinner and this and
that and like you know you maybe stay
home a little more and then she's just
booming and she's like i'm not gonna do
like they just
they had different i just they like
never even fully moved into their house
because like she was so busy and he was
not gonna unpack boxes like it was a
woman's job yeah and also like i thought
one of the most interesting factoids
about like their relationship was like
they were going through like a rocky
time and then 9 11 happened
and oh yeah she like just totally fell
back like into
love like she just made her like realize
stuff you know what i now i'm
remembering it's all coming back to me i
think that the the thing i took away
most from this book was how insane her
memory was because she has these
journals right like it's so
crazy she literally has journaled her
whole life like so these are facts yeah
so i was watching daily pop yesterday
and they were talking about nicolas
saying this and then they were asking
each other if your ex wrote you don't
have an answer no i don't i'm so lucky
but like if
if you if me and ben separated and he
wrote a book and he wrote a memoir but
just oh no but it's the only thing is
it's like you say you're about
twenty percent of you're not the whole
book i would say nickle shape was twenty
percent of the book yeah would you read
it
obviously like are you [ __ ] kidding
me i mean literally i
i obeyed my life like if he
ever wrote a book like
about [ __ ] like i do in the house and
like things i've said like oh my god i
would never be able to leave my home
again like i would become a mole woman
yeah but maybe if you just like ignored
it didn't read it like it wouldn't
affect you like nick lachey
yeah i guess and also like this is like
15 years after
i guess yeah 15 years later sure i don't
care you have a new wife kids
i guess yeah yeah yeah but you know what
i always felt like you're hosting love
is blind right
the thing is is like i always felt like
the way that they broke up and how he
literally started dating
vanessa lachey like a minute later and i
got married and like it's just so unfair
you know like
your ex-husband
marries the next girl and it's like the
perfect love of his life they have a
picturesque family like all that [ __ ] so
you know what i always felt like in the
marriage front like he really got out on
top and now on the book i just feel like
we're even now well i would say yes in
terms of the relationships he got
lucky so to speak and has this wonderful
life but like she also hit the jackpot
in terms of her business and like yes he
doesn't have that he's they're extremely
delicious yeah and she's extremely
a-list so like that's so true everyone
gets dealt a different hand of cards 100
so you would read the book
um
yeah i'm just a curious person like
someone
okay that's the thing i'm i like to
think of a young person that's like an
immature thing that i do i hope that in
15 years
i will be at a place in my life where i
don't give a [ __ ] what people say like
i'm still
like
i'm still emotionally immature like
that's why i read comments like respond
to mean people on instagram because i'm
i have the maturity of a five-year-old
like interesting i hope that in 15 years
like i would be so evolved emotionally i
would be so mature that i wouldn't care
you could be like that's your truth i
remember it differently i think that's
actually a really extremely mature
response i don't know if it's true he
probably did read it but like if it's
true like i have so much respect
admiration and jealousy of your maturity
your emotional maturity yeah
i agree but we'll see where where i'm at
in 15 years probably still reading the
comments probably hopefully there are
still comments about me in 15 years
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
yes
it's the final story
[Music]
and it really hurt my feelings
[Music]
that wasn't pitchy thank you that was
good thank you see you know what i don't
need your approval
right now
because you know if i'm saying something
nice i really mean it because i would
say it wouldn't say it if it weren't
true this is sister's fighting asmr
fifth and final story a little fashion
history news now's your chance to own
carrie bradshaw's tutu from the sex and
the city opener i'll buy it just so i
can burn it same sex and the city
costume designer patricia field has
donated the pink tank top and white tutu
seen on sarah jessica parker in the
series opening credits to this year's
housing works fashion for action
fundraiser
the sale which will also include
contributions from kathy hilton joan
jett and chloe seveny seven yay and more
stars really here's a funny story about
chloe seven yeah sure i've literally no
idea who that is like i know i know her
name is famous but like who is she i was
sitting at psoas once
and i was waiting for someone probably
you
and she came over and like sat she's
like brenda or whatever i'm like no
she's like i'm so sorry like i'm meeting
someone like i don't know and we've
never met so i thought it was you i'm
like that's fine and then maybe it
wasn't you because whoever whoever i was
meeting was like that's clearly seven
yeah i'm like it is she just sat down
that's so funny you could be her brenda
what is she famous for i know i should
have just pretended i think she's just
like
i don't know maybe she's an actress too
i don't know her just give her a quick
google
chloe sevigny is an american actress
model and filmmaker oh she was in
american psycho zodiac okay she's an
actress okay um anyways she's among the
others who are donating um items to
raise money for the organization's
life-saving services and advocacy for
those impacted by hiv aids and
homelessness and while the shoppers will
be able to peruse new designer pieces
marked up to 80 off during the event
we're guessing interesting parties will
need to pony up a bit more dough for
fields special donations yeah i wonder
what it's going to go for despite the
fact that she snagged it for five
dollars back in the 90s she found it in
like an item of five uh
five dollar things and she just had the
idea for
uh sjp to wear it in the opening sjp was
so on board they said hbo and like
darren starr weren't totally sold
but um eventually it made the cut see
that's why patricia field really is
iconic like a five dollar bin an iconic
cultural moment and it'll probably sell
maybe like i don't know is that crazy to
say like 10 grand a couple g's i would
think yeah and especially for a good
cause like ada right you'll be marked up
people are at like sotheby's right it
might go for less but i think this is a
very fun but where um first of all who
do you think is gonna buy like just a
regular person or like
i feel like an influencer would buy it
yeah that's a good point and like
where would they put it like would they
wear it or like you i think it would
have a glass box if it were an
influencer they would wear it if it were
like some sort of collector i can see
like a new york fashion girly who's like
a successful influencer purchasing it
yeah and like recreating the photos i
think that's actually a great idea free
idea for and and you're a fashion girl
who has like 10 grand lying around yeah
there's plenty of you yeah
um so those were our five stories and i
feel like i feel as though you needed to
know them i really really do i feel like
it's been a while since we had like a
robust like this week has been robust
yeah we're three days of robustness and
i look forward to seeing what the rest
of the week brings we're three days of
robitussin
okay so we have a vanderpump rules recap
which is brought to you by framebridge
framebridge makes it easy and more
affordable than ever to customize
to custom frame everything that matters
without without ever leaving the house
from art prints and posters to the
photos sitting on your phone you can
frame bridge just about anything frame
bridge is the perfect way to give a gift
that they'll actually want to receive
this holiday season don't just give
slippers again give them something
special shade shade as jackie's
literally wearing slippers these are
real shoes they have soles go to
framebridge.com and you can upload your
photo or they'll send you packaging if
you have a physical photo that you want
to mail in but it's so easy like when
you're on your phone you can literally
just upload like oh we took this cute
pic let me get a frame from my house
it's so genius and it's reinvigorating
the framing space which is so archaic
and like you go to a framework and it's
like a thousand dollars to like frame
your graduation you have to like that
[ __ ] home yeah it's torture but frame
bridge has it all they have handcrafted
personalized gifts
that are starting at just 39 and all
their shipping is free plus our
listeners will get 15 off their first
order at framebridge.com when they use
code toast they also have stores now if
you're in dc atlanta new york philly
boston or chicago you can do it all in
person but the framerates.com is a
fabulous experience as well get started
today frame your photos or send someone
the perfect gift just go to
framebridge.com use the promo code toast
to save an additional 15 off your first
order that's framebridge.com promo code
toast
framebridge.com promo code toast
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
vanderpump rules last night was pretty
good yeah you know there were moments
where i was in and out on my phone but
then towards the end they really did
they put up they hooked me in and did
you see brock on watch evans live i did
did you see his hair i did he got a blow
out he looked like he just left dry bar
like no i thought he was dressed up for
halloween okay when they were like like
right before he like really introduced
himself i thought like he dressed i
thought it was a halloween episode okay
because like andy made a comment about
his blowout and then sheena posted
something on instagram and i just want
to say julius is the name of the person
who did his hair like he did him dirty
he should have had his hair in a bun he
knew but like yeah but that's brock's
like i don't like julius did a beautiful
blowout it just didn't look great on his
force and he looks really nice in a man
bun yeah no i just i couldn't get past
the hair no it was i thought he was
wearing a wig like it was wild no you
know what he honestly looked like a girl
in her mom it's fun like he had these
curls
it's just weird um but the actual
episode so the thing is here's where i
fall okay
i fall with like obviously team lala
mostly because like whatever team team
tom sandoval's on like i'm standing on
the opposite side of the field like i
just he is the worst judgment he's
literally the worst person in the world
i don't want to be anywhere he is the
worst person in the world like every
week it gets worse and more so and every
week he's like let me go through my
files find something contradictory that
somebody did in these past five years
and bring it up just to make my argument
look better oh randall when lala when
you and randall started dating it's like
that was four years ago that's really
not and i know people are just like lala
doesn't want to talk about herself it's
just like i don't think that's a valid
way to argue with people bringing up
[ __ ] from four [ __ ] years ago no i
mean well the argument to that would be
well lalala's bringing up stuff from 10
years ago regarding brock it's still
going on but
i would like i agree with you completely
um
and also like the stuff with first of
all lala and randall have completely
opened up their lives this season like
we see them in the morning like feeding
the baby like they are actually being
it's not like she's hiding her life
anymore and so four years ago she asked
like the crew the cast to lie for her
because she was dating a married man and
i just like that's just like reality
show tings i'm sorry but a domestic
violence charge in a restraining order
is on a whole nother level and they
cannot be compared i completely agree so
while i do think that a lala really is
coming from a good place but she's also
a reality star she is doing her job like
i also think she's extremely emotional
in new motherhood and she is like
projecting all of her a lot of her fears
concerns and just like you know all
these things that are running through
her mind and she sees like her best
friend in the same spot and she can't
help herself but to like inject her
opinion because it's just so real for
her and i think it's completely coming
from a place of caring me too and you
know what this brock stuff like he just
can't get his story straight i can't
follow anything he's saying on watch
rapping's live he was going on and on
about it and then this morning
sheena like they just keep changing like
the timeline of stuff and it's so
confusing okay this is what china said
on twitter this morning that i was like
it's it's just all so messy she said
and she said he was like dyslexic so
he's did she delete it oh also just to
clear things up with
just to clear things up because brock is
terrible with timelines and
unfortunately suffers from dyslexia but
the domestic violence order was only in
place for about five months back in
2013. i don't know why he said four
years ago the kids came to america and
saw him after that was lifted too just
fyi so they're all over the place they
can't get their own story straight but i
have to say when he said to lisa that he
slapped his wife
i like i
i got like chills like first of all
because if he's admitting that you have
to assume that it's obviously worse than
that that's just like what he's willing
to admit um and i just i can't believe
we're all having this conversation it's
like you know what tom sandoval you like
siding with someone who slapped their
wife like that tracks like you're you're
the worst yeah also i i just love katie
that's all i have to say me too
me too wait i was just gonna say
something [ __ ] i'm like losing all my
trains of thoughts sorry i just keep
like interrupting you that's why yeah no
it was like
um give it a second we'll give you a
moment okay
but now i'm thinking about how i'm so
embarrassed
no putting you someone on the spot to
remember something they'll never
remember it it'll come up in like five
minutes
like you want to just move on it's just
out the door just give me like two more
seconds
this is so embarrassing no time um
you're pregnant
okay i guess we could just um
um
i think i'm getting closer no no yeah
oh grubhub 35
okay um
so yeah i just when he admitted that to
lisa i
i was just
obviously teamwork okay okay so lala i
think actually summed it up really
perfectly and it's exactly how i feel so
i think the way that brock is going
about it on its face like seems kind of
it's an interesting tactic he's being
extremely open i'm watching out inside
he answered every single question he
wasn't offended he wasn't defensive he
says i'm an open book and he's going to
share his story this happened 10 years
ago and like people can change you know
someone can be rehabilitated if they've
been like a bad person in their past so
he's like going about this in a way that
i think everyone else likes someone like
tom sandoval wouldn't no it's like this
was 10 years ago you're different man
but like what lala said is like he's
giving us this like vile package and
then putting a bow on top everybody look
how much
like brock is being honest brock is
sharing when it's like let's look at the
package as well and you know what
there's so many holes in the story and i
have to say andy did a good job last
night because the most pertinent
question of this all is like
you said you wanted to leave australia
to
get a better life for yourself the
american dream in america but like
australia
is a thriving there's opportunity first
world country like he was a professional
rugby player he arguably had a better
life in australia financially and
professionally than he does here he's
like on a reality show he came here to
make a better life for his family yet he
doesn't pay his kids child support so
what better like that's just a lie
detector determined that was a lie like
you're not sending money home what what
is your job here what life did you make
for your vlogging that's better than
being a professional rugby player near
your children you can vlog in australia
the internet is global totally so i that
doesn't add up to me nothing does like
stop saying you came here to make a
better life for your family your family
don't know you they don't claim you they
don't claim you you don't even send the
money home right you're not even doing
what you came here to do and it's like
imagine being his ex-wife in australia
watching him in china and watch what
happens live last night i'm sure she's
feeling justice for herself i'm sure
she's feeling justice for herself but
also like watching these two like try
and con their way like through
explaining an awful situation and you
know what like sheena's probably gonna
end up like paying the child support
that's what i was thinking a hundred
percent yeah
and this is just this sheena's just one
of these people who have
terrible judgment and i think like a
year or two from now like her storyline
will be like you know she was taken for
a ride by brock
yeah this thing i mean i want to believe
one thing about brock though is he
doesn't seem like a villain a bad guy
like he see it's it seems like yes
everything in his past like it's not
good but there it is possible that he is
a better person now and that he would
not do something like that again that
he's learned from his mistakes it cost
him everything at one point and so i
think it's not impossible that him and
sheena like live happily ever after but
like you can't expect everyone to just
hear that
know that you have this new baby
with a woman who is
who is not the she's impressionable yeah
like you know sheena's just she's kind
of the weak link like she's so trusting
she's so nice and sweet like and so it's
up to her friends to watch out for her
sometimes and then they become the
villain i'm sorry i'm grabbing my um
army green chanel boy and i'm leaving as
well that bag was sick her looks are so
sickening everything about her like
everything she she's just so [ __ ] on
point also last week you said that brock
said something that signaled to you that
he might have watched vanderpump rules
previously he said he studied the
playbook he said we're not all suck and
dick for range rovers which is something
that was said previous seasons and like
probably brock had seen it then sheena
spilled last night that like she had
once um adopted a penguin for rob and
then you know without knowing brock
adopted her a koala when they were in
australia and honestly what you had said
the week prior really likes truck accord
with me because it's like he's
definitely studying like he has the
answers to the test and now he's just
cruising cruising totally it'll come
back like i mean everyone's colors like
eventually show especially on these
shows so i mean him and sheena keeps
saying like well you'll see this season
i'm like i'm watching this this she's
watching five like four weeks ago also
but you know what she is the topic of
conversation that's the other thing
they're on this weird transitional
period where all the good people have
left the show all the people who
actually do and say stuff were left with
like the stragglers and lala's making
things happen so sandoval and sheena and
brock are all mad that like something
off camera was said on camera like you
know what i'm actually as a viewer i'm
very grateful what the [ __ ] else would
we be talking about lisa's kitchen oh
the cocktails oh you know you know what
every time
tom sandoval shows up somewhere he
brings like 11 shopping bags and if he's
never invited to my home i hate when
people do that i absolutely loved like
he was making shorts like feel bad about
his simple cocktail he was like you know
me i'm sc i'm extra extra and you're
just like so simple everybody loves
schwartz's cocktail and sandovals will
not be making the menu and i thought
when when he took the thing off and
there was no smoke that was like the
best moment in my life he was like i
didn't see smoke sorry
katie is the unsung she doesn't even do
her say much but when she's always on
the right side and i just think she's
really turning into a season like yeah
she every season is a different journey
for katie and but this season she's just
showing over everyone i said it a few
weeks ago she's giving us nothing
thereby giving us everything yeah it's
just like so stupid like there's such a
clear right and wrong side of this whole
brock thing and like she already hates
sandoval and the fact that and you know
that's the other thing
this has nothing to do with sandoval not
one iota of a thing to do with sandoval
and he's inserting himself when he
totally said give me a [ __ ] second
that was crazy man is out of control
he's unhinged he's losing his mind and
you know what i love that ariana doesn't
stick up for him like it makes me love
her so much like i need them to break up
i know i just like i don't know how she
honestly puts up with him
because she's such like a low-key girl
she's really not like other girls like
she's really low-key and
chill and he thinks that he has to have
some sort of reformation if they're
still together right now because this
behavior is not sustainable i thought
you were gonna say he has to have
something over ariana that's why she
stays with him oh no but that like i
mean i wanna just be optimistic and
think maybe he like turns a corner
because
him behaving this way and by the way her
never sticking up for him which by the
way is so great is everything but that
can't last in a relationship so
something clearly changes between them
because they're still together okay and
also last night was just like the
episode of sandoval being so annoying
like when he got to the restaurant he's
like lights we'll put a light bar the
door the chandelier i'm like shut up
like seriously shut up you've never
owned a restaurant in your life you
barely own the one that you have five
percent of it shut up even when he
walked into poker night and he was like
wearing his hat and everybody's like
i literally my eyes
they saw my brain
[Music]
and i was just like these those moments
are chipping away i agree my soul like i
don't know how much longer i can watch
the show i've lost hannibal's on it like
it eats everything you know the vagina
candle like everything it's like a
moment he thinks he's so funny and
cutesy and gonna go viral and he doesn't
know like with every shopping bag he
brings to someone's home like it's
eating away at the souls of the viewers
but then but like the thing is
like there are people on twitter like
there are people out there no don't say
it
stand balls you're lying that's what
they call themselves no that's what i'm
calling that's a good name that is a
good name and he only needs to see one
comment to note to think he's doing
something right and to keep forging
ahead okay i remember i read something
in vanity fair like a million years ago
when anne hathaway was going through her
like weird thing and the the leading
line of the article was like
somebody told anne hathaway that she was
america's sweetheart and she believed it
and that's literally what's happening to
tom sandoval like somebody told him that
like he's the best part of this show and
he's always right and that we love him
and he believed it so
vehemently it's not even that it's that
he was in like a pageant for america's
sweetheart with seven other cast members
and they all died
and that makes him the winner by default
yeah i guess even though technically i
think it makes schwartz the winner
but schwartz is not an og he never even
worked sir and like schwartz is always
going to be a foil he's never going to
be the leading man nor does he want to
be yeah there's then there's no one
maybe it's james actually like i don't
know where we go from here it's lala
but i guess technically like but people
do not
know i know but by default sandoval is
the number one guy in that class agreed
agreed and it's eating away at all of us
i would rather see brock in the role i
would literally rather see ken yeah i'd
rather see max
brett anyone like i'll literally take
lorelai anyone laura lee whatever her
name was um so that is the vanderpump
recap tonight is part four oh so what's
the deal with charlie oh yeah she wasn't
in the last two episodes she was she was
in last night she got the hot sauce yeah
yeah no and then like she comes in and
it's just like automatically throwing
shade at lala for not like respecting
her dietary restrictions she still
hasn't like really explained them to us
she just doesn't eat pasta no it's like
deeper than that you saw the episode oh
you might have skipped that one probably
there's an episode in palm springs where
like she talks about how she has like
food um
like some sort of food trauma from like
growing up she would like to eat certain
things
um it was hard it was
she didn't fully explain what it was and
it was also like something i had not
heard like it was hard to understand and
now she just thinks that we all know but
we still don't really know i definitely
skip that episode yeah she just has um
just food trauma trauma yeah and
i guess she didn't feel supported by
lala but it was just like
it's just weird yeah um part four of the
real house was beverly hills reunion is
tonight finally i'm like ready for it to
be over andy tweeted like this is the
one they talk about the 20 million
dollars put into ej global the phone
calls from tom her threatening sutton
like it's the it's erica show so that
will be in the tv recap tomorrow and
then thursday's winter house right
no tonight tonight's winter house i hate
when there's two bravo shows like
two hours like i like one hour it's a
nice way to end the night but if it
starts at eight it's okay yeah eight to
ten good nine to eleven back
um so that is our show thank you guys so
much we hope you have an amazing hump
day thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium morning
show where we deliver the fastback
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio cast box all
the places so whenever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning chosen
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
if you've made it to the end of the
episode congratulations you are one of
the very few toasters who actually
listens to the end because you actually
care about our feelings and so
to let us know that you're still here go
drop a comment on our most recent
instagram of the microphone because
jackie made fun of my singing have a
great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow bye